let's take a closer look if we have
solved the problem first of all virtual
machines are nowadays a standard
offering by any cloud service provider
you rent any number of virtual machines
and you pay by the hour or minute or so
this is called ayahs or
infrastructure-as-a-service this is
because a computer and therefore also a
virtual machine can be considered
infrastructure today so getting back to
our original picture problem solved
right we could use standard virtual
machines from any cloud service provider
and achieve unlimited scalability by
distributing the execution of our
application across these virtual
machines on a high level it may appear
so but let's look at what you need to do
to actually realize this architecture
and as it turns out creating this
architecture for your application is a
very complicated and resource intensive
problem let's look at some of the things
you need to think about and take care of
VM Management starting and stopping the
virtual machine operating system images
software management installing caching
and upgrading a powerful web server
installing it and configuring it with
the correct settings a distributed
database where you can read and write
data from all of your virtual machines a
distributed file system where you can
read and write data which is accessible
from all your virtual machines
application monitoring with a
consolidated view of any problems
occurring in your distributed execution
environment availability including data
replication hardware software resilience
Geographic disaster recovery strategies
backups recovery automatic failover
etc security setup and management in
your distributed execution environment
and load balancing how to spread the
load across the VMS including
application level session management and
all of the other things that we did not
have space to list here as you can see
this is an extremely complex problem to
solve in a scalable way so even though
our solution looked good on a high level
we have now created an architecture that
requires a monumental engineering effort
to realize at the same time as you have
limited amount of time and resources
remember that we started the server-side
history by looking at the server city
the office desk and sadly enough for
many projects we have reached the
present day these are the challenges
many projects are facing today when
trying to build scalable systems now
let's do a reality check with the
question for you
since you have limited time and
resources select three of these problems
you would prioritize over the others